[Music]
justice delayed is no longer justice
denied for the passengers and crew
killed 32 years ago this week
aboard pan am flight 103. the london to
new york boeing 747
exploded over lockerbie scotland shortly
after takeoff
all 259 people on the plane
including 190 americans were killed
as were 11 people on the ground this
week
charges against the alleged libyan bomb
maker were unsealed
and one of the most complex terrorism
cases in u.s
history catherine heritage has the story
the quiet night in a scottish village
shattered
by a new york bound pan-american jumbo
jet falling in flames from the sky
all 258 people on board killed four days
before
christmas in 1988 the shattered nose and
cockpit
bearing the name clipper made of the
seas symbolized
american lives lost to international
terrorism
my brother rick minnetti was one of
passengers on the plane outside the
justice department this week
cara weeps told us rick was a junior at
syracuse
university studying abroad in the uk
he was going to live his life to the
fullest in the weeks that he had while
he was in london
along with rick 34 classmates from
syracuse university died
when the bomb ripped through the luggage
hold an hour into the flight
from london to new york's jfk 259 lives
cut
short on the flight 11 more killed by
falling debris in lockerbie scotland
the families have fought very hard over
the last 32 years
to make sure that this was an open
investigation and remained an open
investigation
the pan am 103 case has come full circle
for the outgoing attorney general bill
barr
who led the justice department when
initial charges were made in 1991
we will not rest until all those
responsible
are brought to justice at the justice
department 29 years later
barr announced charges against the
alleged bomb maker
no amount of time or distance will stop
the united states
and our scottish partners from pursuing
justice
according to newly unsealed court
records the bomb maker
abu aguilar mohammed masood confessed in
2012
and carried out the attacks on behalf of
the late libyan dictator muammar gaddafi
the pan am flight exploded at 30
thousand feet
u.s attorney michael sherwin it took
literally four to five minutes for the
debris to hit the ground
it fell into a debris scatter pattern of
over 840 square miles
which was and i believe still remains
today the largest crime scene in world
history
like a giant jigsaw puzzle an
international team of investigators
pieced together the jet ultimately
leading to fragments of the cassette
recorder
packed with explosives it was a copper
piece of samsonite luggage that was only
sold in the middle east at that time
embedded within some of those tiny
pieces of clothing were tiny
pieces of black plastic that
forensically were linked to a toshiba
radio cassette
is there evidence that other suspects
remain out there
from what we understand yes how many
we don't know but it doesn't end with
the bomb maker no
cara still takes inspiration from her
late brother rick
i posted a journal entry that we
got back from the remains that they
found
in lockerbie i think the quote is do all
you can while you can life is a one-time
deal
for cbs this morning saturday katherine
herridge washington
wow for him to be on that case bar at
the beginning and now at the end saying
no amount of time or distance will stop
the united states from pursuing justice
in this case
yeah and for these families it's just
such an agonizing time of year this must
be and especially now with this news
reliving it must be so incredibly
difficult hopefully they get justice
without a doubt